-Willem Dafoe, they love you.
Thanks for coming back
on the show.
-Yeah, my pleasure.
-You look good.
What is the look?
-I don't look good.
-No, you do look good.
-This is for a movie.
It's not for life.
[ Laughter ]
I look in the mirror
and I see Joe Stalin.
[ Laughter ]
-No!
-Yeah.
When I look to the side,
I see a '70s biker.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But that's not what it's for.
-You've never grown facial hair
just for fun?
-No, I have, but, you know,
it's kind of a drag.
When I was younger,
when you grew hair
for a role,
it was something special.
Now, it's in vogue, you know...
-Oh, yeah.
-...and it's almost cooler
to be cleanshaven.
-Oh, thank you very much.
I appreciate that. Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That's why I do it.
-I don't go for the beard
on you.
-Yeah. You didn't go for it?
-No, no, no, no.
-I tried to do the beard.
I just figured I never tried it.
I never actually tried it
and really meant to try it.
-It looked good,
but it ain't you.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah. Thank you, buddy.
I appreciate that.
Thank you very much.
I like that.
I tried it and it wasn't me.
Yeah.
-No.
-No. This is more me, yeah.
-Yeah.
-But you can be a chameleon.
You can do this.
You can do that.
You're always different
in all the looks.
But you're always looking good
because you're a movie star.
-Thank you.
-Last time we were on the show,
we talked about "Spider-Man"
and now, it's made over,
you know, $150 billion,
something crazy-amazing.
But we all love you
as Green Goblin.
-Great.
-Fan favorite.
Everyone loves you.
-Great. Yeah.
Yeah, of course.
[ Cheering and applause ]
But --
-But...
-But there is a thing going
around online
that I was looking at
that everyone wants you
to play a different --
They want you to play Joker.
[ Oohs ]
-Hasn't that been done?
-No, but, but I mean, but --
-You know, talk to Warner Bros.
[ Laughter ]
-Really? I'll talk
to Warner Bros.
Are you guys watching?
Yeah. Hello.
-I floated an idea a while ago,
but it didn't quite happen, so.
-What was the idea?
Can you say it, or no?
-Ah... You know, I --
-You can't?
-Listen, I didn't really
float it to them.
I just mentioned it
in an interview
and then it kind of went
out on the Internet.
But I thought it would be cool
for me to play an impostor,
like slipstreaming his thing.
-Oh, yeah, like,
"I'm the new Joker. I'm Joker."
Yeah. And Joaquin could be like,
"Oh, yeah?"
I love this!
-It would be cool.
-Yes, you could do that!
-But we're doing --
[ Cheering and applause ]
we're doing --
we're doing other things.
-Yeah, you're doing
other things.
Things are going okay.
Yeah. You know,
it's award season now
and I know you've been nominated
for how many Oscars, now?
-Four.
-Yeah. No big deal. Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
Do you remember the first time
you got nominated for an Oscar?
-The first time
I remember really well
because it wasn't as developed,
you know, the campaigning
and all that sort of thing
and my son's babysitter
called me up
to tell me I was nominated.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, and by the time --
the second time, you know,
you could barely
sleep the night before
because you were aware that
the nominations were coming out.
So, it's become
much more developed.
-What was it for, "Platoon"?
Was that the first one?
-First one was "Platoon."
Second one was for something
called "Shadow of the Vampire."
Third was for "Florida Project"
and fourth was
for "At Eternity's Gate."
-And do you get nervous
when you --
Because now you're nominated
and you go, "Okay,"
and you go like, "[ Exhales
forcefully ] I got a shot.
I can, you know."
And is it fun?
-You know, it becomes a game
and you do, you know,
you do your best
to throw your hat in the ring
and try to win.
If you're competitive,
it's kind of fun.
But, you know, it's --
I'll say it, I'll say it.
You're going to hear it.
It's nice to be nominated.
-There you go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
You actually said it.
[ Laughter ]
He actually said it.
Good!
But I think it must be fun.
-But that's not happening
this year, so let's --
-Next year.
Next year, it's happening.
I want to talk
about your new movie, "Inside."
It's a psychological drama
and it's pretty much you
on the screen
for two hours, almost,
and you're fantastic in it.
You're getting great reviews.
I don't know if you want
to hear them...
-Alright, go ahead.
-...but I'm going to say them.
[ Laughter ]
-I'll go like this.
-Yeah, perfect.
Deadline says,
"Willem Dafoe delivers
a tour de force performance."
[ Cheering and applause ]
Tour de force. Ooh, French!
-Oui oui.
-Collider says,
"Everything is glued together
by another Dafoe performance
that proves he's one
of the greatest actors
of all time."
[ Cheering and applause ]
Not too shabby! Come on!
-Thank you very much!
Thank you.
-That is not too shabby.
Oh, yeah, I have this here.
How --
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I found these.
I forgot I had them.
[ Laughter ]
-You --
-Here you go.
Yeah.
How --
[ Cheering and applause ]
I feel I could play your --
-Yeah.
-I could play your brother.
I can play your brother
in the movie.
-Yeah!
-Right?
Come on down.
-Yeah.
We'll go work on it together.
Can we set up the premise
of this movie?
-Sure, yeah.
This premise is great
and it's really simple.
For once.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I play an art thief
that is breaking
into a penthouse in New York.
This place has a lot
of priceless art
and I hack
into the security system.
I go to take three
Egon Schiele paintings.
I go there, I get in,
I'm ready to go, I hack out,
and the system goes awry
and closes me in.
-Yeah, the alarms go off.
-And nobody comes.
I'm stuck there.
The cops don't come.
The owner doesn't come.
All the smart systems
in the house
of this real high-tech house
go wacky
and I got to survive there
and I don't know when
I'm ever going to get out.
And the guy hasn't been there
for a while,
so, I got to deal with food.
I got to deal with water.
And then, with time,
I start to deal with the art
and deal with being there.
And it's interesting
because there's a very strong
narrative plotline
of he's got to deal
with these things
and you kind of figure it out
with him.
But at the same time,
there's lots of interesting
things that are raised
about our relationship
to art and luxury
and what we need
and what's important.
So, it's pretty cool
because it works on,
at least, two levels.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I will say, when I was watching,
I would go,
"What would I do
if I was in that position?"
-Well, yeah,
that's what happens.
-And everyone bails on you,
everyone who planned it out,
and you go --
-Well, you got to deal
-You're by yourself.
-with yourself, you know?
you got to deal with yourself
and you got to figure out
what you need, that's all.
-You guys got to watch this.
It's great.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Willem Dafoe in "Inside."
Take a look at this.
-Go to Tompkins Square Park.
Look for a guy named Danny Z.
He's usually near
the basketball courts.
[Indistinct]
Tell him that I'm stuck here.
No one's come.
-[ Warbling ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Wind whipping ]
[ Tap ]
[ Tapping ]
Do that for me.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Whoa!
Come on!
Whoo!
Willem Dafoe, everybody!
Go see "Inside,"
in theaters March 17th.
Marlon Wayans joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.